Technology is shrinking - smaller phones,
smaller laptops, smaller everything, but
shrinking lenses, like those found in cameras and microscopes, has been a problem.
Material scientists are
trying to replace glass lenses with
something lighter and smaller based on
"meta surfaces" or engineered materials
In this meta-surface lens, tiny towers of titanium dioxide are arranged in a specific pattern to focus light.
Different patterns focus different colors of light.
In a traditional microscope lens the glass varies in thickness between the middle and edges.
Inside the lens the wavefront of light is shaped via different thicknesses of glass.
This focuses the light at one specific point beyond the lens. In the meta-surface lens, the transparent blocks
also bend the light toward the
focal point matching what happens in the
glass lens, but with much less material.
The tiny meta-surface lens building blocks,
about six hundred nanometers in length, can achieve the same resolution and magnification
as a lens that is 5-6 centimeters in length.
Fabrications of these meta-lenses should also be much more cost-effective, compatible with silicon
chip technology versus complex polishing
and sometimes stringent requirements for
high-performance lenses. The next step is
to focus all of the visible spectrum
into the same focal length using a meta-surface lens. Once this happens these
glitter-sized lenses can replace the lens in
a smartphone, regular camera, microscope -
anywhere a lens might be needed and the
great shrinking can continue.